a lot of people get really afraid of
giving away free stuff because they're
like if I give away all this value then
what I do it's like give more value and
if you don't know how to give two types
of value then get good enough to be able
to give value on the front end before
someone buys so they can get value on
the back end because guess what the
reason people buy is because they
predict that they will get value from
you later what is the easiest way to get
someone to predict they're going to get
value from you after you buy by giving
them value before they buy then they're
more likely to buy because you've
decreased the risk because they've
already tasted the sandwiches